[Music]
hello i'm dr peter cerumen and i'm a
world famous urologist think about what
your ears do for you every day they let
you hear things they show off your
jewelry they even hold up your
sunglasses unfortunately until now
science has provided no way for us to
thank our ears until now because now
there's the ralph report the ralph
report is a daily podcast that will let
your ears know how much you love them
monday through friday they'll feel
appreciated as they get to listen to
showbiz news crazy funny weird news
celebrity interviews sex stories sports
stories music movie reviews and much
much more i gotta tell you this ralph
garman guy is nuts
[Applause]
and the unbelievable part is the ralph
report cost you just three dollars a
month that's right three dollars a month
you can get the ralph report monday
through friday for a whole month for
just three dollars do you know what you
usually get for three dollars
crap like this the funny old nose and
glasses bit not even a whole gallon of
gasoline for three dollars you get a
couple cheap disposable lighters
oh [__] is this real gasoline
for just 15 cents a day you could feed
your starving ears at the ralph
report.com
it's time to babble the [__] on
[Music]
it's hollywood babylon
with your hosts kevin smith and ralph
garvin
it is saturday night in san diego ladies
and gentlemen
so let's babble the [__] on i'm kevin
smith i'm ralph garman hey
happy comic-con everybody we are for
those who aren't in the room we're at
the san diego comic-con
2022 doing hollywood babylon here at the
movies pop-up at tin roof in san diego
what a joint this is
a fantastic joint that's been our home
all weekend long uh for for um comic con
uh they let us uh take the place and
cosplay it as a movies and let us
perform here at night do movies after
dark and stuff so it's been
bliss
[__] being here man especially
considering we haven't been able to
gather like this
for three years man there's some people
that like yes yeah
so you and i live in a world of [__]
pop culture and we've shaped our world
to be that so we can interact with the
things we love on a regular basis
some people like don't live
where we live they can't do it as easily
some some poor [__] is the only
ghostbuster in pacoima yes
and so he's just like i can't [__]
wait for comic-con man like cause then
i'm gonna see the other ghostbusters and
for three years that pacoyman
[__] had nothing yeah
but now he's just walking around the
supermarket wearing an unlicensed
nuclear reactor
going are there any are you afraid of a
ghost
so it's nice man that has been able to
happen again i've seen so much joy over
the last few days from people who even
though they've waited in obscene [__]
lines
have been happy to [__] be here like
something that's been missed for a long
time is very very smooth very sweet now
we're starting late because i come from
a hall h panel that went very well thank
you some people were
there apparently
um but we started late because i went to
a panel before that one even longer and
was [__] really wonderful the marvel
panel yeah a lot of news coming in oh my
god we'll talk about that in a minute so
everything has trickled down late we're
supposed to start the show at nine
o'clock it's 10 o'clock so
this is my way of apologizing to all
y'all we got a crowd of 140 here today
ticket buyers this goes out to our
140 ticket buyers who came to support
the show tonight never done this get
ready all right
what's going to happen shout out for
shout out for what
once again the riddler makes no [__]
sense to me
it's just like the batman
three hours of me going what the [__]
he talking about
it's even late in the game you're
throwing the shade at the batman
um look i never done this i think it's
gonna be cool we did the math upstairs
so it ain't gonna break me uh for the
140 ticket buyers who had to wait for an
hour because marvel and then my panel
was late
i would like to buy you a round of
drinks wow
wow
now
there's going to be bottles of champagne
flying around the room i hope you
recognize that yes there's limits to
this
uh the drink shall be no more than ten
dollars
uh and uh if you drink it and you get in
a car accident it's ralph's focus
you know what it's not ralph's fault
it's marvel's [__] fault
[Applause]
exactly
um i was at that marvel panel man jeez
you know we've been uh close close
friends for almost 15 years now i can't
remember last time you ever bought me a
drink that's all i got
am i am i included can we do 141 yes yes
141 drinks include one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
now listen right before i came down this
is the beauty of [__] being out here
in california
my man stopped me upstairs he shoved a
jar of weed in my hand yeah
so [__] big man it's called gak where
is it from
my backyard
this [__] is straight from [__]
oakland look at that look at how much
weed this is that's bad it's going to
last you a whole hour
what a gift thank you for this man
oakland weed [__] yeah i got something
to look forward to so you know that's
like the [__] carrot at the end of
the stick like it's [__] as soon as
this show's over i'm gonna bury myself
in this jar i'm gonna there's enough
weed especially when people give you
free weed you're like i could really
[__] around with it i'm gonna take some
of this [__] rectally i'll tell you that
right now
take all the stems out and just pop it
up there and [__] i've lived long enough
that i'm like trying all sorts of new
things i can tell
what is this more weed
what the [__] is this all about
you wanted to give me a joint since you
were 13. wow your parents must be so
proud
life goals yeah
honestly no [__] aside don't let
them [__] make fun of this moment
because this is real i've been wanting
to give you a joint since you were 13.
so how would you like some of this gak
weed
no that's [__] mine is this
your brand or
just
just a case that you use just something
you found in the restroom
well in the age of post covert i look
forward to smoking this
how are you sir i am ready to go i'm
good to go and so happy to be here uh
smith reached out to me a little while
ago he said i got my own place down in
the the comic con this year we should do
a babble and i was like hell yeah let's
do it i did
i love you too
thank you so much he didn't buy you a
drink
i didn't get any [__] love from again
i gave her a reason to drink
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um all right shall we i i i get yeah
what's the matter
i don't nothing doesn't matter nothing
like literally honestly this moment i've
been looking forward to for like the
last two months me too this was this
represents like kind of the crescendo
the end of my comic con i had a lot to
do yeah you did this weekend because
we're here of course promoting a little
motion picture coming out in september
called clerks 3.
[Applause]
and they said it couldn't be done yeah
oh my god wait wait till they see clerks
nine
[Laughter]
and they said it shouldn't be done
uh cl you get uh tickets right now a
clerk's
three dot movie if you're watching or
listening at home and stuff like that
hopefully everybody here has their
tickets already um so i came here uh
with a lot of uh promotional activities
to do as well as hosting panels and
stuff like that and so this show was
always like the place that i was looking
to get to all h is the you know like oh
[__] i hope that goes well it's the top
of the mountain it really is but
hollywood babylon is the bottom of the
way at the bottom
i could just toboggan down and [__] just
give it a treat it's just so lovely
knowing that like i'm gonna end the
whole thing
sitting next to somebody who knows how
to drive
the show like i could be a passenger you
know i'm an active passenger like
sometimes give me the wheel yeah but
you're like donald trump in that big uh
suv on january 6th
you know we're going to the capitol
no we're not kevin we're not kevin we're
just
going back to comic-con
i want to talk about marvel
it was a good enough joke that i'll let
you slide for comparing me to donald
trump and [__] your hands are bigger we
know
um but it was uh i i don't know man it
was uh what what the [__] was i saying
i'm driving you're a passer that's right
you're the pastor smoking up apparently
yes i did i mean i was happy to get this
but i brought my own as yeah so
um but it was this was the moment i was
looking forward to this was like the ah
i can relax so i'm so [__] happy to
be here that's why i was happy to buy
everybody a [__] drink 10 maximum
that's right
[Applause]
well since i'm driving let me hit the
accelerator do it take us we start off
the show by talking to folks who come
particularly long distances are
celebrating special occasions which
really is everybody here tonight oh yes
but we call it the shout outs
it's a shout out
from kevin and brown so get your [__]
out
[Applause]
you really do have no fear of covet cove
and be damned
you see i'm doing it with a microphone
you see me do it with real people
[__] fearless man i'm looking
doorknobs [__] having unprotected
mouth sex i saw you making out with
william shatner earlier
he's pretty magical man he's he's you
know what i walked away i've always
respected him for being a pop culture
icon but
he's a dude who like i'll go on stage
with him any time because he knows how
to work
his crowd he's sharp as [__] at
91 91 91 man i watched him like [__]
like like play with people in the
audience and and tear them down in a
playful way i hope playful way
but it reminded me of the saturday live
sketch where he's just like get a life
like he was just so [__] good with
them i'll do the voices by the way yeah
my bad sorry
let's all stay in our lanes
what was what would that sound like
get alive
[Music]
i saw you guys buddying up together i
was a little jealous i was like i see a
new podcast in your future what's it
called silent bob and captain kirk what
else would it be called
i'm sure he'd want top billing that's
true yeah
shat and [__]
well can we modify it a little bit
can we throw the in there so it's shat
and the [__] oh i like that
because that way people who could be
like are you the [__] and i was like no
it's basically chat and we talk about
the [__] i'm not named in the title and
they're like i don't know
i'm pretty sure you're the [__]
and i was like well if i am the [__]
it's like i'm the [__] like the kids say
yeah like no
i think you're the [__]
i was like you figured that out
it sounds like a cop show from the seven
shot in the [__] and the [__] this fall
on cbs
after tj hooker was canceled that's
right we tried for one season on a
competing network shot in the [__] went
right in the [__] yeah
or the shatter
depending
uh alex ma are you here alex
alex
hey way in the back hey alex how are you
brother
um alex i know alex a little bit because
we do a segment on a show that i do
called the ralph report where every oh
thank you so much
uh every monday we eat something weird
and so we decided we're going to eat a a
chinese is it chinese alex
chinese delic is he called
hundred-year-old eggs
we did we did eat it
and and it was uh
not i don't recommend it on the reg
was it what it's it's an egg and they
and they uh soak it in a lye
and they let it sort of rot
and then it's a delicacy and then you
eat it uh when it's nice and ripe
and so i was like we should eat those
but i can't imagine we can get eddie now
it's like i can know where to get them
i'll bring them to you so we actually
brought us hundred-year-old eggs so we
ate them on the show
what kind of fear factor podcast do you
have look we're smoking strange weed
from oakland okay we're all taking
chances there's nothing strange about
this weed except like it's a lot yeah
should be suspicious
but i won't be because i'm a stoner
alex said i'll be here down in san diego
for comic-con however i'm also going to
be going to the show with my friend from
australia dr e
oh dr e
hi there he just raised his hand he's a
legitimate emergency room doctor out in
sydney australia one of my comic-con
buddies i go to the con with how do you
guys how did you guys hook up from
australia to glendale
is a romance made in line at comic-con
good for you guys this is a sweet story
man you became friends and you meet
every year at comic-con
that's adorable yeah man that's
something like sleepless in seattle [__]
right there
it's really beautiful man if they take
away gay marriage you can just go to
australia and i'm sure
it'll work out
uh this is his first in person hollywood
babylon i was hoping you and kevin could
welcome him to the con in your best
australian accents
and let him know what he can expect to
see throughout the visit
crikey
fidgery dude boomerang
kuala
steve irwin
[Laughter]
said
that's all i get
um
goodbye
i forgot that one goodbye
that's not a knife
that's a knife
and then this i always go if i try to
get australian i'll be honest with you i
always go for
michael kane in
the dark knight even though he's not
australian he's british yes because he
says a piece in where he goes the size
of a tangerine
and he sounds more australian in that
moment than he does british so when i
need to go to that australian place
in my head i go the size of a tangerine
dr e do i sound it
yeah
and he would [__] know he would know
he's a doctor you got to trust him
good for you man you don't have to save
any lives this weekend man but you know
what we're all here to honor fake
[__] superheroes you're a real one
man give it up for doctor yes saving
lives
saving australian lives he's also a tv
doctor there's a show in australia
called nurses that focuses on er nurses
at his hospital and he was featured in a
handful of episodes
well well well we didn't know we had
celebrity in our house
welcome man is that the kind of thing
that gets a guy laid can you get laid
off that sort of thing
yeah
yeah i can well done dr e yeah
dr eager yes
when i think of australia i think of uh
josh's lovely wife olivia yeah that's
right dr josh right shut up for dr josh
rausch by the way on sights and sounds
who has rarely ever seen
this time you're so close to us you may
you don't like it on camera
talking to the mic you're talking the
microphone jc had to be right here so
now i have to be here for the gears i
hate being on stage so do me a favor
everybody stare at josh oh my god
i want cameras in the air snapping
pictures galore kids
stare at them and lick your lips
makes them really uncomfortable
we also get emails from all around the
world josh
[Music]
featuring kevin's reactions that's right
uh dan ruiz from riverside california
writes in and said i have an idea for a
comic-con this year
could you please have harrison ford sing
the novelty song they're coming to take
me away haha
[Laughter]
at first i was concentrating on the song
but then i went back to who's singing
that's genius yeah
i gotta shoot this i guess we could
since it's all star wars-y and stuff we
could do that give me give me a little
music there josh
[Music]
uh
is
[Music]
there you go there's harrison ford
with all of his energetic performance
[Applause]
[Laughter]
mike ashkew from guelph
in ontario canada oh well everybody yeah
i never have
a longtime listener kevin might remember
from comic book men as the brony guy do
you remember this yeah the brony dude
yeah we did a little episode where they
went to bronycon i was wondering if you
if i could request something funny from
my wife blair she brought tim hortons to
the store for taping by the way
uh if we could have sexy kevin come on
to my wife
come on to her what
just come on to her sexually like put a
move on her oh i thought somewhere
specifically no no no piece of real
estate where she's like come on my
nipples no no
can i ask you can i ask you a quick
question yeah was the weirdest place
anyone's ever asked you to come
eyes nobody asked hey
no free drink for her
hundred and forty i'm back to the number
where's
someone said put it in my eyes
did you [__] run from that person
afterwards i could not comply it felt
too uh too hurtful purposefully hurtful
to do that yeah yeah it was it was a bit
of a mood killer i would imagine yeah i
was like why
because it's dirty and i like it and it
hurts something
[Music]
it also requires the aim of luke
skywalker at the end of star wars man
you'd have to pull out stand up get in
your face like you're [__]
lining up your eyes at the airport and
[__] with that light and then just hit
direct
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the sound of ralph cummings
[Laughter]
i used to target womp rats bigger than
that back at home
her eyes
uh anyway blair is the wife's name could
sexy kevin come on to my wife while this
is a new wrinkle being joined in by
fisto
oh [__]
that's the masters of the universe the
one and only fisto yes all right so wait
wait hold on hold on geez
can tell that he skips foreplay goes
right to the [__] yeah exactly all
right so premature audio
ejaculation totally all right so what do
they want
he wants you to come on to his wife
blair and then fisto is going to join in
at some point during during the the
seduction fair enough all right
all right i'll take that music now
captain oh blair
[Music]
how wide are you
i'd sure like to fist her
[Music]
sorry i'll be over here in the corner
you guys keep going
blair that's a worse mood killer than
asking someone to come in their eyes
can i fister yet yes
you may go i'm gonna watch blair i'm
gonna cut this out
go fisco i sure like to fist you
all right
let me shove some of that open that
oakland weed up your ass
[Music]
seriously
no i could use them this is a sketch
kevin this is a sketch i know but like i
would trust you to do you would be
gentle like a lover yeah i don't think
that's a thing
not yet
but you know what clerks wasn't a thing
years ago and i made that happen
[Applause]
so much so we made a third one
so
[Applause]
so you come three times in 20 years
yes
takes me a long time to recover fractory
periods longer yes
annie and london writes hope you're
enjoying san diego ralph and kevin and i
hope it's not too hot it's been
beautiful down here by the way
absolutely lovely so much so i've been
wearing a long coat i've been i've been
cosplaying as myself
with the heat wave affecting so many of
us this summer
could adam west sing buster poindexter's
hot hot hot for me
annie in london
if anybody could
he can't anymore i might as well have a
little music there boss
[Music]
me mind on fire
me so on fire feeling hot hot hot
[Music]
party people
all around me feeling hot hot hot
what to do
on a night like this
music sweet i can't resist
we need
a party song
a
fundamental jam
swing
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Applause]
we get folks to email us in towns near
them that have [__] up names and we
never really named this segment so we
just call it your town's got a [__] up
name
[Music]
jonathan bellusik from the dorset county
in the south of england writes in
there's a little village near me he says
that's famous for almost nothing except
for its name the village is so well
known that for years trophy hunters keep
stealing the village sign
until the local council had to
commission one carved from a boulder so
no one would steal it that's how popular
this town is it's got a [__] up name
can we see it josh
oh [__] shitterton
i think we've all lived there at one
point
named of course for lord shitterton
no that's not true
i bought it i was like the [__] out of
here named literally because there was a
creek nearby where people would go to
take a dump
are you serious it's really named after
[__]
it's pretty incredible man
it'd be nice to live in [__] didn't
would it it would be the [__]
folks also email us all the time with
stuff that's meant for kids to enjoy
and it turns out these are inappropriate
toys
for girls not appropriate for boys what
the [__] is that
toys
matt sculzy from australia writes in do
you know him dr e
how many how many people could be down
there really
i can't get enough of the show hope one
day you bring it down to australia
people have been asking us for years to
go to australia that's a lot now it's
long it's a long way it's not bad it's
like a long trip it's a 16 hour flight
oh is that all yeah oh well that in case
you could just watch like all the marvel
movies
[Music]
since you're down to comic con and given
your love of adam west batman from the
60s i was wondering if you've ever seen
this valuable antique now this is a
classic people have sent me this so many
times over and over during the years but
it is inappropriate for kids it's a
water pistol
[Laughter]
it's a 60s batman water pistol
the trigger is obviously his [__]
and then people always point out where
you fill up the uh the water pistol
we've got yeah it's a
and it's not like anatomy was different
in the six no not at all it all works
the same yeah really and people often
ask me do you have this in your
collection i was like that's so
insulting to batman would i have that in
my collection well uh
oh my god
unused that's from my own personal
collection and batman was the only one
who was uh humiliated in the 60s with
that they've also got this version if
you're a popeye fan oh [__]
you can grab popeye's [__] too in case
you're
so inclined yeah woody m
elliott glazer from wellingham
washington writes then uh my
girlfriend's nephew was building this
lego set of a tiger on a family trip it
was pretty impressive let me see that
that is pretty impressive that's nice he
was more impressed however when you lift
up the tail of this model when it's all
together oh [__]
you know what that deserves an award for
everything it doesn't yes there's no
need for the kid to lift the tail up and
see the tigers
rusty sheriff badge staring back at him
i think there is i think kids are
inherently afraid of big cats and tigers
and if you see its [__] then you
realize he's no different than me
elliot also says it's got its own page
on the instructions booklet by the way
step 181
he and his girlfriend now call their
[__] 181 by the way
that should be the new term for anal yes
let's get a little 181 going
use that in mixed company
adam gowin writes
i know how you feel about poop toys i
wanted you to know even independence day
july 4th isn't safe from poop he sent in
this picture of a this is a actual
firework
sir dumpsalot is the name of it
it's a dog and let's see what happens
when you light the dog's ass shall we we
got a little video here so we had an
extra pooping dog
[Music]
oh that rocks it doesn't rock
oh my god he's going so hard he fell
over
and then he [__] shorted at the end
you know what man that's ingenuity those
things those snakes that you like
they've existed forever they've already
figured out a new way to do it yeah
that's charming very your dog will [__]
on your driveway
that is the second most delightful thing
i saw today after the guardians of the
galaxy trailer
if only groot was [__] out uh ashes
you would have loved it more don't you
sometimes just want a club that kevin
smith well how about instead you joined
that kevin smith club there are so many
ways into that kevin smith club ladies
and gentlemen you don't have to come
through the front door you can come
through the back door we like it that
way sign up as a clerk where you get
access to all the audio that we got or
join as a mall rep that gives you all
the audio and all the video as well or
join as a fun employee ladies and
gentlemen you'll get a new t-shirt an
exclusive that kevin smith club t-shirt
every quarter or join as a yoga hoser
and get yourself something cool like
that kevin smith waking bake bowl for
2022 we've added some levels including
the fashionable mail you get everything
that the clerk the mall rat the yoga
hoser and the fun employee gets but you
also get once a year an exclusive piece
of wardrobe from a kevin smith film or
join as a brand new ranger danger man
that gives you everything that the clerk
the mall rat the fun employee and the
yoga hoser gets as well as what the
fashionable male gets but then you also
once a year get an exclusive prop direct
from one of my movies and if you've got
untold riches coming out of your ass
guess what holy cow there's the golden
calves level man for that level you come
to my house i cook you dinner we record
a podcast and we shoot it for wake and
bacon it goes up on smodcast join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rep be a fun employee be a yogas or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
i'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that kevin smith club
we also say goodbye to some folks who
passed away recently from show business
who left behind bodies of work will long
remember
but now they're gone and we pay tribute
to them with tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed i don't know if you
were
old enough to watch hill street blues
back in the day when it was on
television are you talking to me yes
you were a kid when that was on [__]
51 i know but you were a kid that [__]
was on in the 80s before [__] long
before streaming and before we even had
cable you just watched everything man so
of course i watched hill street blues i
didn't understand it okay fair enough
but i watched it stephen boschko of
course who later came up with nypd blue
was his first cop show and uh taurean
black who played detective neil
washington has passed away here's a shot
of him back in the day oh [__] died at
the age of 82. he was also the star of a
show called generations it was a a soap
opera on uh nbc back in the late 80s and
it was the first african-american soap
opera on television [__] he will be
missed yeah i remember him on the show
yeah i was one of my first acting jobs
when i came to los angeles was to be on
generations the soap opera
seriously yeah
who did you play what did you do i had a
small recurring role as the major day at
a french restaurant where everyone would
go to eat
like how do i [__] not know this
about you i i'm like an onion there's
many layers you have to peel back
um
has anybody ever seen it no and i've
been looking for it apparently there's
some episodes on youtube but i can't
find mine but i was a young actor and i
auditioned they said we have we only
have one role it's an under five and if
you don't know show biz terms it means
it's like less than five lines so they
don't have to pay you that much but uh
we're going to do you're going to use
your pretty regularly do you do a french
accent i was like
you [__] me of course yeah i didn't do a
french accent
maybe it's better that no one can find
those episodes because i'm pretty sure i
was like oh
welcome to my restaurant
we have a lovely tables for you today
and some baguettes for you to eat
pretty sure i was awful offensive show
canceled that's right yes
and this one really broke my heart uh
shanka dukura i believe is how you
pronounce her last name she was the
actress in the most recent film elvis
with baslerman's elvis with our pal
austin in it she played big mama
thornton who was the original performer
yeah she's she's very electric in the
movie yes big break finally was able to
parlay her blues singing career into a
film and she passed away this week at
the age of 44. very young very young
what happened they don't know yet what
the cause of death was but uh she was
just recently on social media talking
about how blessed and grateful she was
to finally get an opportunity to perform
for such an audience yeah that's here's
a shot of her in that film by the way
she was great yeah yeah
how great was austin by the way we have
a chance to talk about this since the
movie came out you should get nominated
for an award it's it's like he channeled
like elvis i mean i guess he did what we
all did which was like watch videos and
[__] right like he really nailed him it
was a magical performance he was the kid
we goofed around on on the set of uh
yoga hoses he treated yoga hosers
incredibly seriously too though like he
went out of his way to get the canadian
accent right and i was like just say a a
lot you're [__] fine sorry n a
and he was just like no i don't want to
run the risk of offending canadians and
so he really like poured us all into it
he found a regional dialect that really
worked for him and
if i saw him be serious about that i was
like clearly he's
committed as an actor and stuff yeah and
so when they were like oh they cast him
as elvis i was like i could totally
[__] get that man he seems like he's
gonna have a a kind of a brad pitty kind
of career yeah um except he's so ugly
that's the only problem he's so [__]
homeless
looks like he was in an accident or
something i don't know what's wrong i
bet he gets nominated for an oscar he
should i was blown away by that
performance that'd be [__] nuts if he
did and [__] yes
thanks you no i was gonna say he [__]
thanked you and [__] that'd be amazing
he was like this belongs to ralph garman
yes
because he did what i didn't do in yoga
hosers which was being awful and i saw
yeah i said you're going to be better
magic and [__] yoga hosers not only
are you you're so magic and yogo's that
i also put you in
jay and salam bob reboot and uh clerks
three as well ralph is in clerks iii
uh but i just wrote the next thing that
i'm gonna direct which i imagine uh
we're gonna tour
clerks three on clerks three the
convenience tour just like i toured jane
sell and bob reboot on the reboot
roadshow
um we're gonna tour it from september
all the way to christmas yeah and so and
then
the beginning of the new year i think
that's when i'm gonna start getting back
to work and [__] um not just victory
lapping with the movie
so i wrote a flick and i wrote ralph
like a big [__] partner with words
and [__] yeah you got dialogue now
and i sent a ralph a little piece of it
because it's a period piece
and um i don't want i don't want to give
too much away yeah
yeah i can't tell you the story but yes
all right i'll tell you oh come on
ralph's uh dad
back in the day uh ralph grew up in
philadelphia as we all know his dad
worked for
a local version of paramount pictures
what was it it was a regional regional
regional he was the regional branch
manager of distribution for paramount
pictures for the central east coast so
pennsylvania new jersey maryland at the
center part of the eastern seaboard and
what does that job entail
booking
films for paramount pictures into
theaters locally so all the theaters in
pennsylvania new jersey and maryland and
delaware he would book all those films
into those theaters so growing up did
you have access to like posters and [__]
posters press kits soundtrack albums i
mean my room was filled with cool stuff
now i've known this about ralph for
years because when he told me about it
it captured my imagination and as much
as like holy [__] it would have been
amazing to be a kid with a dad that
worked in the movie biz close enough to
get you a [__] poster or something
like that so i was writing this thing
that takes place in 1986
and it takes place a lot of it takes
place at a movie theater
and so
ralph would play the manager of that
theater and at one point
ralph makes reference to the fact that
he was just speaking to the regional
manager from paramount pictures and [__]
so i screenshot that and texted it to
him and i was like look what you're
gonna do in the next movie um and he was
like who is this
yeah and my dad passed away a couple
years ago so it's kind of cool that i
will be referencing him in a film yeah
unless ben affleck's available and then
i won't be in the movie yes
holy [__] if affleck can do that
i recognize that justice with affleck
comes damon i know it's not lost i'll
have a co-manager
i get it i absolutely get it
speaking of that sure they have feelings
about their fathers as well i'm sure
they do yes
speaking of bad acting we do a segment
here uh called exquisite acting where we
realize that sometimes bad acting can be
so bad it goes all the way around to
become exquisite
to be
or not to be
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with ralph garman and kevin smith
uh this comes from dan in california
this is another classic from the uh the
film mortal kombat we have a lot of
films that kind of like
yes
you were supposed to come in with that
part i'm sorry sorry
you don't even know the [__] song man
i have no idea you were [__] just
scatting your way through it like
scabbity-boo
i was getting laid back then
it's one of the most amazing songs on
the planet man it pumps you up i don't
give a [__] what you got to do it's just
like
masturbate masturbation oh you're chaff
you'll chafe don't masturbate to that
fair enough
uh 1997 of course this classic
film
uh talisa soto
musetta vanders who we feature today she
is the the exquisite actor in this scene
from mortal kombat annihilation
mother
you're alive
too bad you
will die
oh man
wow
acting comes down to choices that was a
big one that was
you could drive a truck through the paws
sure can too bad you
one mississippi two mississippi me mom
three mississippi will die oh got you
okay moving on
we also find mistakes things that
bloopers weird things and moments and
films that just go by the audience until
someone points them out and that's what
we do here in [__] that should not be
and now for [__] we should not see
here's some [__] that should not be
jesus ramirez writes in i've decided to
show my kit
no i'm all good thank you
decided to show my kids what i think is
the
best and original superhero movie
superman from 1978.
but this struck dick donner superman
dick donner superman he said this struck
him as [__] that should not be however
when he's dealing with lex luthor in his
lair under the subway there with all his
strength power bravery and knowing
luther's evil plan
why does superman flinch
he's got a point superman's all scared
in this one moment in the film and i
looked at it and i was like i don't get
it either it's [__] that should not be
well
what do you think suit baby
interesting well your theory is quite
impressive luthor oh would you go to the
viewing room
please but as for the rest it's nothing
but a sick fantasy
the fantasy
no no
it's history it's happening superman
mitch [__]
[__]
ow lex you're so loud
super hearing yeah he's superman what's
he afraid of
valerie bryan's tits
this is a big reaction i never noticed
that it is indeed
let's take a look at all the
entertainment news in a segment we call
the hbo headline
give me head give me
[Music]
sylvester stallone's upset
right
who's being who's being greedy and lazy
now yeah
you hit it right on the head is it
really the producer of the rocky
franchise erwin winkler is now
in his crosshairs and also in his 90s i
think yeah when winkler is a very old a
very old man and he wants erwin winkler
to give him the he's 93 by the way wants
him to give him the rights to the rocky
film franchise including creed which he
also owns because he was the producer of
the original rocky right he's he went on
social media with a portrait of erwin
winkler with a forked tongue as a
serpent
and said
this is a very flattering portrait of
producer erwin wigler
one of the country's greatest
just being sarcastic there yeah after
irwin controlling rocky for over 47
years and now creed i would like to have
at least a little of what's left of my
rights back so i could for you pass it
on to your children a little bit on my
children
so he's complaining he didn't make
enough money off a [__] rocky i know
um i mean
like i i don't
i got no skin in the game but it feels
like you signed a deal long ago and it
also made him who he is that's my point
no one wanted to hire him and he won an
oscar from it so it's not like wow
[__] rocky i had to take it in the
shorts but it helped build my career
it's like it sometimes it kept earning
for him he's got to give to get right so
he gave up some points at the top of his
career and then he became so rich
so very rich but it wasn't rich enough
and yes he did come up with it it is his
brainchild yes no man is an island and
no no never would have been made if erin
winkler didn't take people to
and erwin winkler was successful what he
did brought it in and right and it just
feels weird at this late stage in the
game to be like trying to take money
from an old man before you died
i want you to give me all your money
right
so that like i can have all your money
and have all my money and your kids have
no [__] money right it's basically
what he's saying to him i mean i get
like the notion where he's like why
why should this guy be able to leave it
to his kids i created this i should be
able to leave it to my kids but right
when you make a flick you sign all that
[__] away unless you make it
independently or something like that and
you know unless you've got the foresight
to be like i'm going to carve out rocky
and own that myself which never would
have happened he's the titular character
yeah no one's going to go for that to a
first time writer
star for that film you never would have
made that deal not at all no do you know
i own jay and salam bob me and jay muse
own jane salambot that's a good thing
we don't obviously i'll never own clerks
again in this lifetime but i'll never
[__] about it because it gave me
everything right and i was there was a
time where i was desperate to [__]
sell clerks i wanted somebody else to
own it and [__] give me money for it
that would make me feel like a
professional anyway so i don't have
regrets about that like oh my god i i
wish i still owned clerks you know i'm
i'm happy that somebody bought it and it
changed my life but right before we
closed our deal my lawyer john sloss was
just like is there anything else you
want to put in the contracts at sundance
we made a deal to sell the movie but it
was written on yellow legal pad and then
you know you go home and it takes like
months to do a real contract and [__]
contract's about to close so john sloss
is like is there anything else you want
to add before this all closes up and i
was like you know what
i know i'm going to use jay and salam
bob in another movie so can you see if
they'll give me permission to use them
in mall rats because i know i want to
use them in this movie that i'm writing
for universal and john sloss is like
i'll do you one better i'm just going to
ask if you can own the characters and i
was like can you do that and he goes
it's the [__] law we make it up all
the time
so he went in for the negotiation and
talked to them and [__] like that and he
came out one day and was just like
congratulations you know you own jay and
silent bob genius and i was like how the
[__] did you pull that off and [__] he
was like it was very simple i told them
that you know kevin smith so you know
he's very interested in in keeping uh
rights for the characters of jay and
silent bob from his movie clerks and the
miramax lawyer was like who is that and
what the [__] is clerks and so once he
stepped him through it and [__] he was
like uh you know it's a movie about
these guys that work in a convenience
store and he goes uh huh and who are
[__] jay and silent bob and he was
like well those are the guys that work
they lean outside the convenience store
on the wall and [__] like that and he
was like well why does kevin smith want
to own this
and i asked my lawyer i was like yeah
why did you say
that i wanted to own it he's like well i
[__] shot the moon and i said this
and i said uh
the guy
who plays jay
is actually named jay
and since miramax is owned by disney
he's afraid if miramax buys this movie
clerks that disney will own him for the
rest of his life
so he wants to carve out the name
exception because that's actually his
name and i was just like and they
[__] went for that they [__]
believed we were that stupid and my
lawyer goes because you're both from new
jersey yes
and so john sloss told me he's going
i'll tell i was like and how did it
happen he goes i'll tell you the exact
words that they said to me these were
the exact words that granted me
ownership me and jay of jay and silent
bob which i should say
is like owning
not star wars but r2d2 and c3po in star
wars like you can you could they've been
an umbrella my whole [__] career
whether [__] was up or down the fact
that we owned jay and salam bob and we
could do anything we wanted with them
and stuff monetize them go out and tour
as jay and sal and bob get old which had
nothing to do with the movies and [__]
all those options would not have been
open to us had we not owned these
characters this these were the words
that the lawyer said i asked john sloth
i was like what did they [__] say and
he said the miramax lawyer was like
um okay we came to a conclusion he's
going he can own jay and silent bob and
he goes really he goes yeah the movie's
called clerks it's about the guys inside
the store not the guys outside the store
he can have his characters and i'm not
being facetious and i'm not being
[__] shitty and i'm not trying to
[__] uh drop information or anything
like that i'm just being real with you
all
like i've made a lot of money off of jay
and silent bob yes a lot of [__]
money man
and
telling that story mount just makes me
want to text my lawyer and be like thank
you
so it's possible one could own one could
own like retain ownership rights if he
had had the wisdom way at the beginning
of his career to be like i'll sell rocky
the movie but i get to own rocky it
never works i want to own paulie
[Laughter]
so you know like paulie can go on tour
you know and like stand outside the gym
and things you know
yeah that would have been fantastic
tom cruise is thinking of leaving
america
why we just all embraced him again
because of top gun and [__] i guess he
took all our money and now he doesn't
need us anymore
yeah he's like i got your money you
[__]
he's looking to move to london he's
shopping for a home in what they call
millionaire excuse me billionaires row
in london
it's where uh richard branson lives and
robbie williams and a bunch of other
british stars he's [__] losers
yeah those guys wow he's gonna live
amongst the super rich he's not content
to live amongst the rich he's like i
need to live amongst the super rich he
apparently has fallen in love with
england and he wants to make it his home
oh right on good for him yes
spread scientology far and wide wherever
he has to go
[Laughter]
i like women you can just say that okay
they'll believe him in england
uh no we won't someone said
peter jackson has announced that after
the success of get back that beatles
documentary did you watch that i don't
know if you're a beatles fan i
a casual beatles fan but i did not take
in the entire documentary it's a long
watch uh nominated for five emmy
nominations oh [__] that's very
important uh he's announced that he's
looking to do another project with the
two remaining beatles paul and ringo but
he said it won't be a documentary that's
all i can really say
they're going to play hobbits yes
um wow look what i found pole is a ring
we should probably put it in a mountain
all right let's go
i'm in
it's like yellow submarine meets the
hobbit man look how big my feet are and
they're all hairy i know look how big my
nose is
miriam margulies are you familiar with
miriam margulies british british
character actress very talented versus
one of the harry potters or a few yes
she was recently interviewed and she
said
that she does not care for one big
hollywood star they worked together in
1999 on a film called end of days
arnold schwarzenegger is who she singled
out i remember that movie i do too in a
movie theater she played satan's sister
yeah
and she said while filming that movie
she'll never forgive him
he was quite rude actually she said
he farted in my face
ow
she went on to say now i fart of course
i do but i don't fart in people's faces
he did a deliberate hell of a notion
right he did it deliberately right in my
face
during a scene he had me in a position
where i couldn't escape and i was lying
on the floor and he just farted in my
face
i haven't forgiven him for it
she's still carrying the grudge
rightfully so man so much so she brought
up in an interview years later yes she's
really upset about it i can imagine that
wasn't pleasant for her but maybe it
wasn't on purpose no way
no you know you eat as many blood bursts
as i do it's just gonna come out all the
gas you know
and if i sit on your face and i spread
my cheeks i call that red heat
unfortunately i was going commando
[Laughter]
i became the predator
holy [__] did you see the trailer
for prey
yeah
movie looks [__] amazing man it looks
so [__] good indeed
oh we got to talk about it we have no
choice every once in a while we
mentioned justin bieber he's in the news
this week
justin bieber
nobody [__] needs you
you wanna know why
i'll tell you why
tragic news uh justin bieber has
recovered from that illness that
paralyzed half of his face oh good for
him man he's back now he's going back on
the road to complete his justice world
tour
he is going to be in first of all south
america south africa the middle east
asia australia new zealand circling back
through europe and then he threatens to
return to the united states he was
battling a disease called ramsay hunt
syndrome
or ramsay [__] syndrome in this
particular case
it's a virus that paralyzes half your
face and uh he said that he was
concerned but now he's happy to announce
he's fully recovered it's like a bell's
palsy kind of thing kind of like that
yeah my dad had that i remember at one
point half his face like sloped for a
year or something this guy got off light
yeah
um he massaged it with a lot of penises
he says
is that the secret that's the secret
yeah
it's where uh it's where it's all
happening right here this weekend comic
con so we might as well talk about
little geek news
[Music]
yes indeed can i start please do so i
was in hall h i went to the marvel panel
went to the marvel panel
[Applause]
wow um it was it was packed so i thought
all of comic-con was there it was pretty
astounding dude i
i completely fanned out my panel was
after theirs and [__] so i got to sit in
the back backstage saw every [__]
person that they put up on stage all the
marvel universe stars come in and that's
pretty cool let me ask you let me direct
you real quick i'll let you finish go
ahead i'm like kanye i'm gonna let you
finish yes
in many ways you're like kanye
i wondered this and i've never asked you
this question but it comes up to me
every time i think of you backstage at
hall h do you at this stage in your life
and career ever get star struck because
of all the people you work with all the
people you interview all the panels that
you host when you're standing backstage
and
superhero after superhero walk past you
does it faze you at all now or is it
just business as usual no i i i mean i
wasn't like non-plus by the whole thing
but like i was like oh i get it they're
here to promote a thing
and i
like it occurs to me from time to time
like i i watched the
they put up four trailers they put up
the trailer for she-hulk which is legit
funny and [__] look like the john
burn run of she-hulk she broke the
fourth wall talked to the [__] camera
she used to do in the book so i was like
holy [__] that's awesome then they
showed a trailer for secret invasion
which was way more intense than i
assumed it would be it's very
oriented
um i thought it was gonna be like the
scrolls comedy hour but it wasn't really
that at all then they showed uh at the
end they wrapped up by showing twice
uh the trailer for wakanda forever which
looks [__] epic and included
submariner yes which was [__] magic
man um and the whole thing was very
emotional
that whole aspect of the panel because
naturally chadwick boseman we lost a
while ago and stuff but the third
trailer man was guardians of the galaxy
vol 3
and i swear did they put it up online
not yet it is honestly like
if this is the trailer the movie is is
gonna cleave my heart and twain it was
one of the most emotional experiences
i've had in like the last 10 20 years
now i'm known for like crying on the
internet yeah i like everything i would
have seen something about that i'm a
middle-aged stoner so everything [__]
touches me but oh my god
like
he stuck it's beyond he stuck the
landing like to to get away with making
guardians of the galaxy once and making
it something that it became this magical
one-off and [__] you know it's [__]
billion in one shot and then to repeat
it
with with volume two it's like holy [__]
he kept it going
what i saw today was so [__]
undeniably beautiful and incredibly
moving and made with so much heart man
there's a shot of rocket in the trailer
that
instantly i started [__] welling up
with [__] tears
and started like [__] getting real
emotional and [__] and my kid harley was
sitting next to me and [__] i fed
just as like i was rolling tears i felt
like this hand on my [__] leg she
grabbed my leg i looked over and she was
bawling twice as [__] hard and this
was from a [__] shot in a trailer of
a raccoon
yeah yes
yes was he going through garbage
no no no okay
[Laughter]
he looked so scared it was so beautiful
man it was really [__] touching whole
[__] trailer has this epic conclusion
feel to it but it was you know it felt
familial it felt like you were with
family i'm telling you is one of the
best trailers i've ever seen in my
entire life was absolutely breathtaking
and makes me want to see that movie a
thousand times more desperately than i
ever wanted to
the rocket story line 10 it promises to
be a [__] journey like an insanely
emotional journey
i'm [__] here for it man because like
james gunn and friends took one of the
dopiest [__] ideas like the [__]
space raccoon who could [__] talk and
they're turning it into something which
what i saw there's only two minutes and
change and [__] if it's what it looks
like it is
that could win [__] oscars
like so don't say that again that's not
going to know [__] killed
you said it about spider-man piece of
[__]
but it was so [__] profoundly
powerful and he managed to do that with
a [__] cartoon raccoon man that's
crazy beautiful so i i had like just
such a wonderful moment in hall h with
the kid
watching that just like i i devolved
into utter fandom i i stopped thinking
like a professional and that's why i
love those marvel movies because they
let me like hang up everything else and
just be like a fan again i sat in the
back and i was a kid watching trailer
after trailer to be like oh my god this
bucket makes me feel like movies made me
feel when i was a kid in the 80s right
so there's nobody that like that i saw
that like oh my god i'm tongue-tied or
whatever [__] i see him and i'm blown
away like holy [__] it's them holy [__]
it's them i saw james gunn and i
desperately wanted to attack him after
they came off the stage but i figured
he's in the midst of a bunch of things
it'd be weird if suddenly like silent
bob was like
[Laughter]
but he would understand it because i did
it to him once before when stan got his
feet and his hand prints in the chinese
uh of groman's chinese theater cement
and [__] um i was the emcee and this is
after i think guardians volume two came
out and james came up be one of the
speakers as did the late great chad
mcboseman uh but when i saw [__]
james i hadn't seen him since i saw
[__] volume two and i ran he
i remember he turned around because i
was coming toward him and stuff and he
goes hello kevin and i just [__]
tackled him with a hug
and held him so tight and i was like you
were doing the [__] lord's work man
it's sometimes nice to have the job that
we have i'm sure you've had experience
with this but like
just like y'all like there are people
that i would love to tell things to and
express like what their art has meant to
me and periodically because of the job
we have i can do that yeah you know i
could probably do it too on twitter just
as easily but like
it's more meaningful to have that
[__] moment and you know if there's
an added layer to it because whether you
respect me or not for what i do i am
also involved in the arts and have been
for 30 years so i have something of a
chairman emeritus status of sorts and
stuff like that so
when somebody who's like the elder
statesman or somebody who's been doing
it for a long time or somebody has their
own [__] fandom and [__] like that to
themselves
like throws it all the side to be like
you are [__] doing it man like you
are what fuels me and [__] you know
sometimes you wonder
the chef feeds you who feeds the chef
right i feed myself on a steady diet of
all sorts of cinema but the cinema that
like raises my heart makes me
feel like i did when i was a kid about
movies is marvel so being in the back of
that panel like was one of the most
delightful experiences i've had at any
comic con least of all this one it was
nice to be back after so many years and
it's incredible to be here with the
[__] clerks three we showed the first
five minutes of clerks three in hall h
after the marvel panel like the place
was packed they loved it
but the highlight of the con for me was
watching that trailer
like you could i saw the entire
guardians of the galaxy cast standing in
front of me also watching the trailer
backstage also getting [__] emotional
and they know the story right and
they've been there and made the thing
and they were all [__] like getting
like red eyed and [__] hugging and
[__] like that it was really really
beautiful and that's what comic-con is a
series of these beautiful moments yes
it's lines and heat and [__] like that
but
it's all of that to get to that moment
where you're like that will never happen
again it only happened here man and it
happened in a really magical time the
movie will come and go one day and i'll
be able to watch guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 uh repeatedly on my phone if i
want to but right now it's a [__]
mystery a magical mystery it's a promise
it's a promise it's honestly i [__]
i'm getting all emotional i turned to my
kid when i saw that [__] shot of
rocket and i was like that's one more
reason to stay alive [__] like i
must see what happens
and that's what those marvel movies make
me want to do they make me want to live
to the [__] next one i'm like all
right [__] i got one more reason to
stick around i hope they make this [__]
and i have to live to be 200 and [__]
that i'm just a turnip that they feed
with a tube and i'm like oh groot
just make my smile i'll also let you
smoke with a tube though right yeah well
that will [__] of course groot is my
what i call weed so that's why i'd be
like groot kevin also announced in the
hall h that he's going to recut clerk's
three and put a raccoon in it now so
i'm telling you that shot that looking
forward that shot was incredibly [__]
moving they're telling his backstory and
james said it on stage he goes i like
i'm going to cry talking about it he was
like i always wondered like he's like i
know he's this cartoon squirrel or wise
crack and squirrel but he's like he's
alone
he must be the loneliest person in the
universe and he goes i always wanted to
tell that story and based on what i saw
[__] nailed it like i didn't know how
much i wanted to see that story i was
like
show me now um
i might hit up james and be like i'll
show you clerks three and i'm sure you'd
be like i don't want to see glory
that's not a [__] bargain for me oh i
gotta see it i gotta see what happens
but you're right it's hope it's promise
it's something to look forward to man
[__] that trailer look good i was
profoundly moved by it marvel also
rolled out their next phase for what
they're going to be doing with the event
that happened too in five yeah [__]
kevin feige was there the only kevin
that matters in this business oh stop
absolutely kevin james is still somebody
that as well
son of a [__] but
he was up there and he showed us like he
told us when phase four is ending we
pretty much knew but he told us
everything in phase five and then at one
point he was like hey man who wants to
know how phase six begins and ends and
we were like what the [__] do you have
the information no no i just i was
reading do you want me to tell you yeah
phase six begins with fantastic four
shut the front door
phase six ends with two avengers movies
the first avengers movie is avengers the
kang dynasty right and the second one
[__] clench get ready
avengers secret war
[Music]
[Applause]
if i was a betting man i would bet the
russo brothers be coming back for it
well they've been dancing around that
conference the one they said they'd come
back for if it's secret wars yeah um
they laid out all of uh phase five which
i didn't memorize there were too many
but i was memorized the other one
because there was only like those three
yeah
what
[__] yes you're absolutely right
daredevil was one of the in phase five
and it's not just daredevil it's how
many episodes
18 [__] episodes of a daredevil
series not just that i don't know if
this is the storyline they're doing but
they're calling it daredevil born again
yeah
which is one of the greatest [__]
story lines ever written in a comic book
yes frank miller wrote it with dave
mazza kelly and because of the
multiverse ben affleck is putting the
costume back on oh no no no no i heard
it
multiverse daredevil where they duke it
out they announced that it's well they
didn't announce that they announced that
charlie cox is doing the voice of
daredevil in the animated the anime
spider-man freshman we know that charlie
cox is coming back to be our [__]
daredevil man in the trailer at the end
did they put up the trailer for she-hulk
at the end of the [__] she-hulk
trailer man the billy cub shows it we
see the billy club [__] daredevil how
could he not he's a lawyer too right i'm
telling you man like [__] i don't
mind geeking out about this [__] i
[__] love it like it's my it's my
fandom it's my heart every one of those
trailers i literally was like this
backstage and [__] i was creeping out
people [__] like people who were
sitting there waiting to go up on the
panel i think paul rudd thought i was
breathing down his neck
but i just wanted to see past him to the
[__] trailer i [__] love this [__]
man it was a
which one
they did flash bill murray in the that's
right we saw another trailer we saw
ant-man quantum mania and they showed
[__] all right modoc was in it man
what
yes [__] there's a shot of modoc and
then peyton reed on stage copped to it
he was like yes that was modoc in there
i was watching i was like is that
[__] motor and it was [__] motoc
and he looks like modok
big old head just running around yes
that movie looks [__] wonderful as
well um yeah oh my god they just brought
the goodness man they made up for three
years of absence i know going into the
con a lot of people were like are they
gonna bring everything because uh like
d23 is happening we've been hearing
they've sort of been backing off stuff i
mean i look i don't know how it felt i
honestly felt like they gave it right to
the balls i don't know that there's
anything left
felt fully [__] after that panel
thoroughly satisfactorily [__] wow
yeah
it was tough to do my own panel after
that you were spent i was just like i
got nothing as good as that here's the
first five minutes the balls were empty
yeah i was done
well speaking of marvel i don't know if
anyone saw it this weekend i've only
seen photos but uh they have released
the real life infinity gauntlet
merchandise piece have you seen this no
if you're a marvel one at home will you
put on you don't have this one at home
oh although you might want to pick it up
okay it has been unveiled by marvel
merchandising they did it in conjunction
with a jeweler
it is an infinity gauntlet sounds like
something tom cruise could buy yeah
he might have to sell his house in
london in order to get it though they've
swapped out all the infinity stones with
actual
rare gems okay
so the time stone for example is an
actual emerald from columbia the space
stone is a sapphire from madagascar the
reality stone is a ruby from mozambique
the power stone is an amethyst from
unknown locations the soul stone is a
specite
and the mine stone is a yellow diamond
together the six stones are more than
150 carats
in jewels you can own this kids
for the low low price of 25 million
dollars are you [__] [__] me for
this gauntlet
and it comes with the gauntlet too you
get that for free it better come with a
[__] glove
that glove holds all the actual
gemstones in place for the display but
the value of the stones combined is 25
million dollars
at that size i mean one of one i meant
one of one but it's available for
purchase should you be so interested
maybe after clerks nine you could
finally scrape together remember how
much i was just talking about how much i
love marvel apparently there's a line
for 25 million that gauntlet better jerk
me off by itself
man
and or more in my ass or snap you off
yes whatever it takes all right before
we say goodnight kids we have one last
bit of business to take care of uh we
often talk about one of our favorite
actors liam neeson not
not so much for his work but for his
prodigious penis that is the stuff of
legend and so we ask the musical
question
william neeson's [__] is so big
[Music]
you folks can send in your own facts
about liam neeson's [__] to hbo podcast
at aol.com
oh really quickly one last moment if you
couldn't get in tonight because this
sold out pretty quickly if you're in
southern california you can come see us
in burbank california next month on the
5th of august at flappers comedy
technically my birthday show i'll be 52.
exactly yes
and the last show for a while because
kevin's going to be in airplanes and
buses and cars for the remainder of this
year right taking clerks three on the
road on the convenience tour so you can
get tickets for the babylon show at
flappers on august 5th at uh
seesmod.com coming so i should point out
folks we batched up everything in order
to make room for the show but if anybody
wants any of the we got these amazing
shirts that the roosevelt's people made
that the staff's been wearing
um and spirit jersey the good folks at
spirit jersey made amazing shirts and
stuff so
james luke over there man like before
you get out of here you're like i want
to buy one of them shirts they'll help
you out instead speaking of shirts have
you seen who's down down front here i
saw that the whole [__] show that's
classic right that's an og hollywood
babylon shirt with kevin as uh green
arrow and me is green lantern hard
traveling babblers yeah
from the earth where you're gonna find
improv that's early early babylon merch
man yeah it's year two or three we start
selling those at uh at uh john lovett's
comedy club i think oh he who shall not
be i'm an [__]
[Laughter]
i couldn't help myself
[__] prick i'll never forgive him i'm
like it's like it's like arnold
schwarzenegger farted on my face that's
how i feel about john is that long i'm
never going to let that go i feel you
all right
liam neeson's [__] is so big
kate bush be running up it
[Laughter]
ah timely and classy
yeah
liam nieces [__] is so big
pete davidson has decided he's going to
date it
liam neeson's [__] is so big
his orgasms are longer than this
pandemic
william niece's [__] is so big
slugworth offered charlie ten thousand
dollars to let him have one
it's a reach back to willie
and lastly liam neeson's [__] is so big
elon musk tried to buy it but then he
got scared and backed out oh
ladies and gentlemen of san diego have
you had a good time this evening
[Applause]
if you did it's only because of the man
sitting next to me give it up for the
one the only
he trained he got down here for you
ralph [__] garmin ladies and
gentlemen
and please give it up for my bestest
babble buddy and brother mr kevin smith
[Applause]
and that is hollywood babylon for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm ralph garman
babble the [__] off good night san diego
comic con
give it up for ralph garman and kevin
smith
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith